[Applaudissements]
marquez quoi ou alors bonne chance aux
courses mais pas laisser de fer l'acier
s'occupait lorsqu'il est soumis à côté
c'est ce à quoi on a l'impression
qu'elle est dit et à se taper sur belon
et ça c'est vrai que c'est ça paris
valérie c'est la pudeur les les valeurs
d'autrefois notre maman a tous des cons
l'avant on envie de la tt facon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça va je fais du vélo après ça va aller
passer fait du vélo s'il faut ou non
mais c'est pour ça que dans l'équipe de
touche pas à mon poste bas tout le monde
adore regarder
[Musique]
ces grands gagnants de cette première
édition ces rives sont là 7 et rentrer
l'art y est on peut dire que tu habites
orange se dit oh non
maintenant
[Musique]
allez vous êtes la série bah oui moi je
sais vous divertir heureusement que vous
êtes là il est approuvé m sont là c'est
dans je sais pas pourquoi c'est la
foir'fouille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]